I'm Dr srinayak scientist and
immunologist and I'm here to answer your
question from Twitter this is immune
support
[Music]
Pediatrics can playing in dirt help your
children's immune system absolutely so
in the field of Immunology there's this
idea called the hygiene hypothesis we're
almost hyper clean now and that we're
over cleaning ourselves and that
microbes are in fact good for us and
they help our immune system and they
strengthen our immune system and
evidence from this comes from sort of
these remarkable studies done comparing
children that grow up on farms with
children that grow up in City settings
and the incidence of autoimmune diseases
or diseases where the immune system has
gone Haywire are much much lower in the
the sort of farm kids or the rural kids
than in the urban kids or the city kids
Roger bezaniff asks in the 1950s the
tonsils were routinely taken out even
though they're a fixed part of the
immune system
why parents were gullible tonsils are a
gland that are part of the immune system
so they are like lymph nodes they reside
right here and they swell up when you
have an infection because that's where
the immune system organizes so in the
50s and 60s a large number of children
had their tonsils removed when they were
inflamed with this thought that tonsils
were Reservoir were disease struck but
then the medical establishment kind of
moved away from that because there was
very little evidence that this was
helpful to remove your tonsils to
prevent recurrent disease folks are
still undergoing tonsillitis or tonsil
removal but only in the cases where they
actually have recurrent strep infection
or in some cases of sleep apnea Monica
lebranch asks what controls your immune
system what organs or glands I'm
wondering about this this is a great
question so your immune system in fact
develops in your bone marrow from your
bone marrow also in glands like your
thymus your spleen and your lymph nodes
and these are really centers where the
immune system is acting out of think of
them as sort of fortresses within the
body that unleash immune cells to the
rest of your systems as they're needed
Zach weiner asks are viruses alive so
viruses are this incredible gray area
between alive and dead is a rock alive
is this table alive no because they
can't replicate or make more of
themselves on their own without help
from another cell another creature so
here we have one type of this type of
virus infects bacteria and right here we
have a virus that infects mammals or us
what these creatures do is they infect
cells they hijack they almost parasitize
the resources of that cell to make more
of themselves and spread and so we think
viruses are this gray area between alive
and not alive that are really sending
our heads for a tailspin immune system
quiz asks how do mucous membranes work
as a physical barrier to defend against
disease the way mucus works is it
essentially creates an even greater
separation between our body our physical
barrier and the microbe and these are
particularly important for instance in
the intestine which is densely packed
with microbes and so the mucus just
allows the microbes to sit in between
our intestine and not even touch our
body's barriers Reverend Jake 97 asks
what does the spleen even do so the
spleen is this bean-shaped organ that's
right here it does quite a few things so
it houses immune cells and recycles iron
and it also gets rid of your red blood
cells that are pretty old you don't need
a spleen surprisingly if you get rid of
your spleen the liver takes over a lot
of the functions of the spleen so again
our body is really really adaptable it's
a it's a very fine-tuned machine the
list company asks is chicken soup good
for the immune system what natural
remedies do you use to combat sickness
I'm a scientist So my answer is going to
be a very scientific answer I don't use
natural remedies to combat sickness I
use what we call empirically tested
medicines one thing we need to think
about when we think about medicines is
how these medicines are developed how
they're rigorously tested I don't think
that kind of study has been done with
chicken soup yet and so it's very hard
to say does this actually work in a
medical setting is it delicious does it
taste good of course pyramids RM the
immune system consists of a group of
cells tissues and organs similar to the
Army and each of them perform specific
functions to attack any enemy storming
the body so how does the system work so
first of all I just want to congratulate
pyramids are on a beautiful analogy
because it's exactly how it works the
immune system is essentially our
Safeguard against Invaders and the
second we have an Invader a pathogen a
virus a bacteria that crosses our
boundaries the immune system can sense
this pathogen consensus disturbance and
respond and try to kill it eliminate it
troyella 5 asks questions for hashtag
Immunology Twitter I didn't know there
was a hashtag Immunology Twitter if
antibodies to hashtag covid-19 don't
last very long in the body how effective
can a hashtag vaccine be really great
question really important question so
yes antibodies don't last very long
because they are proteins and proteins
are not very long-lived but what are
very long-liveter cells and so the cells
that make the antibodies we call them
memory B cells are very long-lived and
in fact live for decades sometimes
following certain types of vaccinations
so those are the powerhouses that last a
long time and so even though your
antibody tighter or the antibody levels
May decline the cells that make those
antibodies are being stored and being
preserved Tampa Bay news asks the thymus
gland how does this little known gland
help your immune system so the thymus is
a very very important gland in fact
because it is where a key type of immune
cell develops the T lymphocyte so the t
lymphocyte is part of the the T cell or
the T lymphocyte and I think I have a
picture of this guy here
I mean stem it's this little cell it's
actually really an important part
because it helps directly kill virally
infected cells and it's also being
harnessed to fight cancers the thymic
gland is right here it sits right above
your heart below your sternum and this
is where these T cells develop where
they form where they learn and then
they're sent out to the body to patrol
so nisi asks does anxiety and depression
have an effect on your immune system the
immune system in the nervous system are
much more closely connected than we'd
realize when you have an inflammatory
reaction your nerves activate and in
fact there are some really interesting
early studies that show that memories of
immune systems are remembered in our
brain and of inflammation are remembered
in our brain and also there's a lot of
evidence suggesting that when you're
stressed you have essentially more
vulnerability to infections you have
more vulnerability to inflammation there
is this interconnectiveness that's now
starting to be unveiled Joe baby Chase
asks what are lymph nodes lymph nodes
are the centers that are basically
fortresses throughout our body they're
glands throughout our body that
aggregate the immune system so all of
our tissues are constantly being
monitored by immune cells and these
cells will flow into the lymph node when
there is something bad like a pathogen
going on where they can orchestrate an
immune response and you can think of
this as sort of a border with a fortress
there's you know soldiers at the border
and if there's some there's something
bad that happens Sentinels go back to
the Fortress where they can organize a
larger Army and then send them out to
the border to fight
nhmamd asks how can people with HIV live
a healthy lifestyle what's amazing and
again credit to Medical Science is that
HIV is no longer a death sentence we
have a number of different drugs that
control the virus and in fact can keep
viral numbers in the body so low folks
with this infection can go on to live a
very healthy life
antiretroviral therapies and
preventative measures like chavedov have
really helped limit the Infectious
effects and also the transmission of
this devastating pathogen Nicole
hallaman asked specifically where does
the waste go after a macrophage eats
bacteria or virus is this why people
sneeze and have extra mucus does it come
out in urine okay good question so first
let's talk about what a macrophage is a
macrophage is a cell of the innate
immune system and it's actually a cell
that is essentially like the garbage
collector of the body you find
macrophages all over your body in every
tissue everywhere and they're really
good at eating dead cells dying cells
they're really good at eating bacteria
the macrophages is remarkable because
it's not only a garbage truck but it's
also helping break apart the bacteria
kill it disintegrate it and get rid of
it Andy lindenberg asks why do fevers
always Spike at night how do they know
that it's night so our body has a
remarkable system it's called the
circadian clock it's a cyclical clock
that's within all our cells that kind of
gives it the sense that it's day in or
it's night and the cells behave very
differently and so one of the reasons
fever Spike at night is because your
cortisol levels your hormones are really
really controlled by this clock and
cortisol suppresses inflammation
suppresses uh immunity and so at night
the cortisol levels go down and your
inflammatory response goes up and so
this is sort of the natural circadian
clock and so you feel fevers more at
night
lindy2350 asks asthma is defined as a
lung disease but is it also accurate to
call it a disease of the immune system
because similar allergies it's sparked
by an overactive immune response slash
inflammation that is correct Lindy or I
guess Melinda asthma is a disease that
manifests in the lungs and it affects
your breathing but it's a disease that's
caused by hyperactive immune cells these
immune cells are once again cells that
where the break has been taken off their
activity and they're sort of turned on
and behaving in a manner as though
they're trying to get rid of a pathogen
or a bad guy but in fact this time they
are causing lung disease or asthma Carly
with three eyes asks I hate having
psoriasis like what the expletive even
is psoriasis where did it come from why
do I have it psoriasis is in a disease
or condition which manifests as sort of
scaly plaques redness itching swelling
and the underlying cause of this disease
is a miscommunication between immune
cells and your skin cells it means cells
think they're fighting a pathogen or
they're helping repair tissues when
really there's no pathogen or tissue
repair needed the squatting man asks
what does autoimmune even mean once
again it's in the name autoimmune so
self Auto itself and immune so
autoimmune is when your immune system
now instead of activating and fighting
pathogens is recognizing your own cells
your own proteins as bad and attacking
them so one example of this is diabetes
when your immune system thinks that your
cells that make insulin are bad guys and
attacks and kills them and so you're no
longer producing insulin cert lab
question for immunologists outside of
the recognized genetic disorders what's
known about person-to-person variation
in immune function thinking about when
people say I have a strong immune system
I never get sick it's a very astute
question and it goes down to this
fundamental property of nature versus
nurture right how much of our the way
our body works is encoding in our genes
our DNA that code that makes us and how
much of it is the things we're exposed
to in the world and turns out the immune
system is one of those remarkable
systems it senses the world it learns in
the world and so it's really in a large
part its function is determined by all
of these extrinsic factors in a really
dramatic way so evidence for this comes
from studies at an identical twin so we
know that these twins have the exact
same genome exact same DNA because
they're identical folks have looked at
the immune system in these twins and
what they they find is that there's
remarkable differences in the way these
immune cells function in what types of
immune cells there are and so what that
tells us is even when your DNA is
exactly the same your experiences has a
huge tremendous impact on how your
immune system works outflanked s so
anti-inflammatories bring down fever but
fever is part of the immune response to
fight infection does bringing down a
fever prolong recovery this is an
interesting question because yes fever
is part of the immune reaction and
though the thought behind it is that
pathogens are really good they're
adapted to our body temperature so if
the body increases its temperature it's
no longer hospitable to a pathogen and
so that's one way by which the body is
trying to get rid of this pathogen but
what we have now are really remarkable
antibiotics anti-fungals antivirals and
so we use those to eliminate the
pathogen and so the fever strategy May
no longer be necessary and doesn't
really affect the prolonged recovery and
finally Dr Carl can you catch the same
cold twice yes you can absolutely catch
the same cold twice and I want to
clarify you know if you're vaccinated
against a cold you can still catch a
cold but what happens is your body has
learned to deal with this bad pathogen
whether it's a virus but as a bacteria
whatever and so the second time you
catch it chances are you're going to
clear it much much faster and we know
this and certainly the examples with
covid have been very clear where once
they're vaccinated the numbers of folks
that were hospitalized that were really
experiencing severe disease was much
much lower because their immune system
has now been educated on how to control
the pathogen that's it that's all the
questions and I hope you learned
something until next time